des griffes et un chat au québec serait
interdite dès 2020 une cape il toulouse
où la pratique revient amputer les
doigts de l'animal à la 3e challenge
autrement dit elle lui couper le bout
des doigts ou des orteils qu'est ce que
vous en pensez parmi eux c'est vraiment
douloureux pour l'animal comme angers
100% entre autres les greffages et cette
interdiction à venir est un combat de
longue haleine pour des défenseurs des
droits des animaux il ya vraiment des
conséquences à long terme pour certains
chocs à qui subissent un dégroupage dans
la douleur chronique des changements de
comportements des trucs comme ça
pourtant la pratique reste courante
beaucoup de gens comprenaient
pas tout le monde disait qu'ils à
l'épaule faire juste parce qu'on on
essayait de pousser à ne pas le faire
hors taxes étaient aussi prévus ces
corrections à le faire mais pour
plusieurs une question d'honneur alors
qu'est ce qui arrive si le pousse trop
loin ils nous demandent les alternatifs
donc installer des poteaux à gries pour
les shows de poser des prothèses greffe
aussi pour protéger les meubles donc son
sort s'est mise à son corps face à des
gens en plus du dégriffage des animaux
domestiques le nouveau règlement
interdira aussi la coupe de la queue ou
des oreilles pour des raisons
esthétiques un grand pas pour la
protection et le bien-être des animaux
québec écrit le ministre de
l'agriculture andrée lamontagne
on va pas assez loin pour le bien-être
animal maintenant si on parle avec notre
tête mais on comprend que tout une
législation derrière ça il faut laisser
le temps aux juristes de faire leur
travail par apparation mais est ce qu'on
peut retenir c'est que c'est un pas dans
la bonne direction une nouvelle
législation qui ne sera peut-être pas
sans conséquences j'ai l'impression
qu'on va peut-être avoir quelques
abandons pour deschamps qui vont
détruire en appartement le québec
emboîte ainsi le pas à d'autres
provinces comme le nouveau brunswick la
colombie-britannique où l'île du prince
édouard qui ont déjà interdit le
dégraissage des animaux domestiques tout
comme une quarantaine de pays ici daniel
k jaws radio canada montréal